I have a theory that
Floyd Mayweather is the greatest great
of all time meaning he is greater at his
skill of boxing than Stephen Hawking was
at science okay then I can live with
that but I don't know if I would call
him the greatest fight of all time first
of all Floyd Mayweather is one of the
greatest ever
um he's a brilliant brilliant brilliant
defensive fighter his speed his bass is
boxed and Savvy he's just a savant he's
just something special no question about
it
but I gotta look at the Sugar Ray
Leonards of the world so you came up at
a time where you're watching Sugar Ray I
watched Sugar Ray I watch Peppino Cuevas
I watched Thomas the Hitman Hearns
Hagler Mugabe yeah all of these cats I
mean you know uh you know um uh what's
his name Aaron Pryor Alexis Abuelo
Salvador Sanchez
yeah I'm telling you right now you can
look out across alley Foreman Frazier
Norton Shavers all of these guys right
it's not just about your skill set it's
who you do it again your level of
competition is it possible that he's so
far beyond his level of competition that
he made it look easy well I think he did
as a lightweight when he went up to the
welterweight division not so much you
know I'm saying now if I mean
well he just gave him a boxing lesson
but two in the canola was 22 years old
see I remember that's an excuse though I
don't like this like he's 22. I'll tell
you this well you know you do have to
take that into consideration I think I
had 100 questions well let me explain it
too you have to take that into
consideration when boxing is the issue
now if he got knocked on his ass that's
different
but when he simply got schooled when you
swing in a punch and Floyd is tapping on
your shoulder saying I'm behind you
that's a problem you understand that's
just a skill like you know you we could
credit Floyd with that of course I am
crediting I'm saying he's a brilliant
brilliant boxer you know this Floyd knew
how to move before you even threw the
damn punch you see what I'm saying you
got to be a veteran and know how to
overcome that you can't put a novice
into the ring with Floyd Money
Mayweather yeah you understand he's
going to school you yeah what I'm saying
to you is that if you want to make an
argument on Floyd Money Mayweather's
have which I'm not similarly dismissing
yeah I would tell you it's this
Floyd Money Mayweather
was undefeated for the last half of his
career with one hand
he constantly broke yeah he constantly
broke his hand and so because he broke
his hand you got to give credit where
credit is due he would go into a ring
knowing he had no shot at knocking
somebody out because his hands were hurt
too much and literally walked in the
ring and said I'm gonna embarrass you
and humiliate You by showing the world
you can't hit me we were in Jacksonville
he hit Arturo Gotti
but we were in Jacksonville Florida
Philadelphia Eagles were playing among
New England Patriots in the Super Bowl
and it was a week before a few days
before the game
and I'll go up to Floyd and I'm like
look man you know this
[__] man this is modern day Rocky
you can't play around with Gaddy you you
gotta you gotta take him out you can't
play
I'm just I'm just telling you we're in a
VIP section Floyd grabs me pulls me
closer to him
ain't no [__] with six losses
beating me I can't ever forget that yeah
I said what music blaring VIP section we
in the club the whole [__] he said I
said
ain't no [__] with six losses
ever beaten me go watch yeah so I said
fine I'm gonna beat it fight was in
Atlantic City yeah I flew back from
Jacksonville and I went to Atlantic City
yeah for the next week for the fight
and Floyd beat that brother
it was bad it was it was it was a point
in there Roger Mayweather like looked at
the cameras like come keep watching this
ass whipping yeah and Floyd hit that
brother with like six rights I said oh
my God just picked him apart yeah just
like he told me he was gonna happen
there's uh my dad used to be a a
journalist he would go to Ali's Camp a
lot and um he asked Ali before he fought
for him and he's like how the hell are
you gonna beat this guy remember Foreman
that was performing hit Frazier and
lifted him off the [__] canvas with
an uppercut yes yes and uh and uh and uh
Ali told him he was uh you have to
understand like I'm a scientific boxer
he goes this this new stuff this is what
you do you know you could be the best at
this but I'm the greatest ever at this
right and it is a science to me and I
have figured out how I'm going to break
this guy down now the irony is he went
in to the ring with that plan and he was
like this [__] ain't [__] working I
need to lay on these ropes but that's
sort of great that's the greatness of
Ali for sure but there's certain guys
that you can just well it's funny you
bring that up because I write about it
in my book that's my father's
funniest mode I've never seen my father
laugh harder than when foreman not
Frasier upside the back of the head for
that final knockdown
my father laughed about that until the
day he died I mean it's 50 years didn't
spending 50 years he still laughed at it
till the day he died about how Frazier
got now because he end up see somebody
get knocked the back of their head that
way Fred the foreman hit Frazier and and
Foreman was menacing you know Foreman
was arguably the most menacing box in
history people talk about Mike Tyson go
back and watch watch more of it and our
former scared the living hell out of
them but when you think about brilliant
boxes yeah Floyd's up there Sugar Ray
was Ali of course the greatest because
who went through the diversity that Ali
went through which is why we call him
the greatest yeah but Floyd's up there
he's in the discussion yeah okay so the
the question is obviously Brady's
retired yeah and I think a lot of people
are like
I think they're hesitant to be like he's
the greatest athlete ever I think he is
do
ofus of all the word athlete has no
business in the same sentence as Tom
Brady because in terms of that wasn't
what he was he is an elite pastor of the
football and an elite football mind
which both contributed to him being the
greatest quarterback ever but he ain't
the greatest athlete that is not true
what makes you an answer yeah well speed
quickness agility
um along with various other skills that
come along with the respective sport
that you're in Tom Brady didn't have
those things you know what my Francesca
formerly a mic in the Mad Dog radio show
they were on my show first take last
week
and they had they had their reunion and
Mike Francesca made a very valid point
he said I love Tom Brady he's got the
greatest quarter resume as a quarterback
ever he's the goat no doubt about it no
shade throw on him he said but we need
to understand he's not he's not he's
neither the greatest regular season
quarterback ever that was Peyton Manning
and he said nor is he the greatest Super
Bowl quarterback ever that would be Joe
Montana
he said those two quarterbacks he said
you're talking about Tom Brady Tom Brady
was neither the greatest regular season
quarterback nor the greatest Super Bowl
quarterback but that's 10 Super Bowls
versus four I understand that but what
I'm saying to you is that Tom Brady say
what you will the fact of the matter is
that was factually correct
well I I would just disagree with the
greatest because it's not winning
percentage to me it is if you got to
take everything into account well well
well then don't then take everything not
just would you want to like for example
you look at the AFC East well the Jets
the Miami Dolphins and the Buffalo Bills
spent years being retouched so you are
automatic you are an automatic top two
seed in the AFC for years yeah you
guaranteed a home playoff game at
Foxboro okay most of the time two games
in AFC Championship game so you gotta
take that in account right then you got
to take into account the first three
Super Bowls Tom Brady won is because of
that defense New England
Bill Belichick coach defense he
obviously was a defensive coordinator
before he became the head coach Ty Law
and McGinnis and the rest of the crew
the defense led the New England Patriots
not the Patriots offense they LED but
the winning Drive was always Brady I
understand that that was everything well
you could say that well what about the
losing drive because guess what uh in
the AFC Championship game he couldn't
put together a winning drive against
Peyton Manning Peyton Manning had beat
him you also got to remember in the
Super Bowl Eli Manning beat him twice
yeah Eli got him talk okay so you got to
look at all that and by the way he
should have lost to Seattle if Pete
Carroll and Daryl Beville didn't call
the stupidest play in NFL history when
Marshawn Lynch is running wreaking havoc
over the New England Patriots get you to
literally the half yard line and they
decide to have Russell Wilson throw a
pass over the middle that gets
intercepted by Michael and Butler at the
half yard line this is what they did he
should have lost that Super Bowl he was
down 28-3 against Atlanta but
Dan Quinn and Kyle Shanahan decided not
to run the football and throw the damn
football so an incomplete pass stops the
clock which gave New England all the
Time in the World to come back and erase
the 25-point deficit when they were
supposed to run the damn football so
there's a lot of things Ryan took that
sack that took him out of field goal
range that we ended up letting New
England come back so all that I get but
again to me overall encompassing 10
Super Bowls is crazy that's more than
every team ever well nobody's saying
he's not the goat they're just saying
that you could be the goat without being
the best regular season or the best
Super Bowl quarterback that's what
they're saying they still called them a
goat yeah they're saying but he's not
the greatest regular season quarterback
and he's not the greatest Super Bowl
quarterback but the athlete conversation
is I thought there's an athlete someone
who plays a sport because the best
athlete is probably some CrossFit guy
but we're not going to call them that's
fair I get where you're coming from but
I guess what I'm saying is when we look
at a respective Sport and we Marvel at
the greatness of a player yeah it's not
used it's usually because of what they
do that's true through but when you say
athlete you take into consideration a
multitude of things Prime Time Dion
Sanders is the greatest cornerback that
ever lived but damn could he play wide
receiver and damn could he return punts
and kickoffs too yeah and damn when he
got into the open field you could pick
the fastest dude out there they had no
shot of catching him which is how he
came up with the dance because he could
afford to dance because there was nobody
on his heels because he would just run
away from the crowd because that's how
lightning fast and quick Prime Time
Deion Sanders was there's a multitude of
things Bo Jackson baseball and football
and you sort of Versatility of his skill
set and the repertoire that he had
available to him you looked at that
Caitlyn Jenner one amends decathlon as a
woman that's amazing think about it
that's impressive that's pretty crazy
he's like the mouse is watching
so then maybe the greatest athlete of
all time is Usain Bolt
okay because everybody in the world is
run straight
not everybody's played baseball not
everybody's played basketball you can
say he's the fastest man but again I
said versatility when I came when it
came to Athletics I didn't say speed I
said versatility so you say you saying
vote I'm just talking speed I'm talking
versatility so Bo Jackson runs you know
runs over I hear it you know yeah he
plays baseball Dion was playing baseball
Dion played baseball and football as
well so who's your number one number one
athlete of all time yeah
a lot of people try to say Jim Brown
because he played football in Lacrosse
lacrosse apparently he was amazing at La
Crosse the greatest he was the greatest
amazing at lacrosse I'm gonna tell you
it's a cross between prime time Dion
Sanders and Bo Jackson
that's me in terms of athleticism yeah
okay um if you want to tell me Lebron
because I can imagine LeBron on the
football field what about Tiana Trump
because a lot of people don't know
him
amazing skill sets no one to talk about
diversity
you never opened the door one time
open the door say hello it's very nice
to meet you sorry not interested we're
on this evening look at the peephole one
time no no look at the people when I
open the door yeah